ich stehe hier neben der siegerin
unserem wettbewerb die bratwurst des
jahres mich sabrina hofmann aus der nähe
von kassel hat sie kreiert und da ist
sie auf dem grill
herzlichen glückwunsch sabrina du hast
mich riesig gefreut du hattest tränen in
den augen
ist das wirklich ein toller erfolg für
die ja auf jeden fall ich könnte da sein
aber also für uns eine große anerkennung
praxis zwischen so vielen einsendungen
wir freuen uns
was genau gewusst das ist eine
hausschlachter bratwurst waren
verarbeitet
genau aus dem stahl direkt von uns
geschlachtet
ja und innerhalb von wenigen stunden
gleiche arbeit und du hast die fahnen
hochgehalten jetzt für die ganze familie
vielleicht mal der der ehemann den haben
wir auch noch herr hoffmann wir haben
sie hätten nur ihre frau so sehen sieger
aus die sich ganz deutlich ihre frauen
axel wirtschaft ev ist das wirklich
super gemacht
sigrid bei uns zu hause auch immer sonst
hat einfach ein händchen für die schönen
dinge im leben also auch für die schönen
parade
ja also toll vielen dank nochmal
herzlichen glückwunsch sie haben eine
trophäe gewonnen und dürfen natürlich
das logo bratwurst des jahres jetzt
nutzen nicht vermutete ganz deutschland
wird jetzt scharf sein auf diese
bratwurst wir hatten hier wirklich einen
ganz ganz tollen tag theresa wirklich
mit mit tollen kandidaten mit tollen
favoriten und einen besonderen muss ich
auch nochmal markus semmler sterne koch
markus was sagst du wie viel wert ist
wie fanden sie die qualität der würste
total klasse wirklich total
unterschiedlich vom vegan über geflügel
fisch schwein rind dabei
unterschiedliche geschmacksrichtungen
aber landsmann hat sich durchgesetzt da
bin ich auch glücklich drüber richtig
klassische bratwurst super vorarbeit
also vom schwein vom hof war
geschlachtet also warm verarbeitet heißt
nicht in die kühlhäuser sondern direkt
verarbeitet mit dem gewürzmischungen des
hauses dazu die wirklich auch den
feinsten damen gehabt alles rund alles
super also ich hab gesehen das war ja
auch quasi die erste bratwurst und du
hast gleich gesagt ja eine landsmännin
das klang schon so ein bisschen
nach favorit weil die wurst super war
also ja es gibt halt ganz
unterschiedliche geschmacksrichtungen
aber die war wirklich perfekt gemacht
sie war saftig
da hat alles gestimmt deswegen im 1 wenn
das der sternekoch sagt reza du siehst
also wir hatten jede menge spaß wir
haben eine tolle siegerin und mit einer
tollen trophäe
fahren sie zurück in die nähe von kassel